und dann nach dem mittagessen hat meine
mutter uns beide meinen bruder und mich
zu sich geholt und hat uns gesagt also
das attentat auf den führer
das war der papa
[Musik]
stichwort zeitreise waren wir vielleicht
mal an mit dem 15 16 17 paar tage vor
dem 20 juli 1944 wo waren sie da und
woran können sie sich ändern
also ich kann ihnen die tage jetzt
stehen wir so genau sagen aber alle
anfang juli war die schule in bamberg zu
ende und ich habe da die aufnahmeprüfung
ins gymnasium abgelegt und auch
bestanden und danach sind wir überzeugt
dieses gymnasium nie mehr wiedergesehen
ja und danach sind wir zu meiner anderen
großmutter väterlicherseits auf die
schwäbische alb gereist und da war eben
dann einige tage später ich kann sie
nicht genau sagen wie viele plötzlich
die nachricht im radio im einstigen was
damals in dem großen anwesen war das ein
attentat auf den führer folgt worden
sein
und jetzt wollte ich von den erwachsenen
wissen was denn da los war aber total
wusste nicht zum teil wollen sie wohl
nicht sagen
mein nächster jüngerer bruder und ich
wurden dann auf einen langen spaziergang
mit dem bruder meiner großmutter
geschickt und der übrigens auch mitglied
der verschwörung war und später
hingerichtet wurde
grafik skrill ja und dann nach dem
mittagessen hat meine mutter uns beide
meine nächste jüngeren bruder und mich
zu sich geholt und hat uns gesagt also
das attentat auf den führer
das war das papier was natürlich ein
riesenschock für uns war das sofort in
haltloses weinen ausgebrochen und ich
habe gefragt ja wie kann man jemanden
den führer umbringen wollen
da hat meine mutter gesagt er wollte es
für deutschland tun also nachher später
hat sie gemeint so hat er gesagt er
hätte sich gilt aber das stimmt nicht
wir sind mein bruder und ich uns ganz
einig ja das konnte ich natürlich auch
nicht auf die reihe bringen
und eigentlich habe ich das nicht
verstanden
in der ganzen zeit danach kam nun viel
konnte mir meine mutter nicht mehr
fragen denn in der nacht wurden sie
abgeholt und dann waren wir da alleine
ja das war natürlich eine schwierige
zeit
und wenn das dorf nicht so fabelhaft zu
uns gehalten hätte dann wäre es noch
schwerer gewesen ja denn nun waren wir
ja der vater waren verrätern wir waren
verräter kinder können sie sich noch
daran erinnern wie sie sich gefühlt
haben
sie sagten ihr jüngerer bruder seinen
tränen ausgebrochen
wie war das für sie ja aber wunder
natürlich genauso
also ganz ehrlich waren schrecklich den
vater zu verlieren obwohl das ja
durchaus nicht und auch mal war in der
zeit habe ihn ja schon vorher gesagt
also ein großer teil meiner
klassenkameraden hatte ihren vater schon
verloren
unter anderen umständen natürlich als
ich und ich konnte nicht glauben dass er
etwas falsches getan hatte aber auf der
seite konnte ich auch nicht verstehen
wie man den führer umbringen wollte ja
also das hat lange gedauert bis sich das
in mir gesetzt hat und hat uns ja auch
keiner was gesagt hat ja keiner mit uns
darüber gesprochen also vorher auch
nicht also sie wussten gar nicht mehr
nein nein also
richtigerweise haben meine eltern nie
mit uns darüber gesprochen
denn kinder sind gefährlich die
verplappern sich ja dass du es eben was
mich unterscheidet von den älteren
damals schon ja die auch in diskussionen
einbezogen werden konnten und mussten
auf ihre eltern standen da habe ich
meine hätte mein vater seine wirkliche
meinung und das war sehr getan hat mit
uns geteilt das ja dann ist das gleich
bleiben lassen können das war einfach zu
gefährlich
wie eng war denn ihr verhältnis früher
zu ihrem vater ich meine der war ja auch
viel weg an der front in einer leiste
640 war nur sehr gelegentlich da und
länger haben wir eigentlich nur gesehen
nachdem er schwer verwundet worden war
da war er zur rekonvaleszenz längerer
zeit damals waren wir auch schon auf der
schwäbischen alb
weil unser wohnort wuppertal sosehr
bomben gefährdet war
also 43 von sagen wir mal juli august
september wahrscheinlich gar nicht so
lange wie ich heute meine war er dann
natürlich nur noch mit einem auge mit
einer hand mit splittern im knie kann
man kann man in so kurzer zeit überhaupt
eine tiefe emotionale bindung zu einem
fahrt aufbauen oder ist das einfach
jemand der kommt und wieder in ein
wahres wesen einer also das ist nichtig
weil er die frage kann ich natürlich
eigentlich nicht verantworten für uns
war so in unser vater den haben wir
geliebt und wir wussten jetzt nachdem
der krieg ausgebrochen war dass er ins
feld ziehen musste und da aber das war
ja bei den anderen fällt dann genauso
aber das hat nichts an seiner
seine stellung in der familie geändert
nur hatte meine mutter dann die last die
familie am laufen zu halten
sie konnten für sie war es ein schock
als sie gehört haben dass ihr vater
dieses attentat verübt
wie war denn ihre ganze einstellung zum
edler und zu den krieg zu denn die war
so wie wir damals alle waren wir waren
auch jan aufgewachsen sind dafür eben
der führer ist und der das ja die
höchste autorität ist und wie ist der
schöne spruch in dem lied führer befiehl
wir folgen dir das hat man einfach
akzeptiert ja und damals mit 10 musste
man ja das war pflicht
das deutsche jung volk wie das hieß das
war sie waren die kleinen bei der
hitlerjugend eintreten
ich war drei tage zu jung
stichtag war der 30 juli dritten juli
geworden
und ich wollte mich freiwillig melden
was das war der bei der mutter sabotiert
der gesagt ja das ist so schnell
gewachsen und ob das gut für die
gesundheit gut ist und so also wir
lassen denn dr schuss sei dass unser
arzt entscheiden na ja der war natürlich
geimpft und hat sich dagegen
ausgesprochen
aber die masse meiner klasse waren als
für die hebung folgt dann war er einer
der jüngeren in der klasse habe ich
hingekommen natürlich es war immer so
ein bisschen weil meine mutter hat
durfte uns nicht zeigen wie sich das
zustand nur hatte ja also ich halt nie
enthusiastisch für den führer geäußert
und mein bruder hat sie erklärt warum
uns auf unsere musste muss alle
augenblicke flaggen ja die flagge
raushängen
warum unsere kleider war als sie vor den
nachbarn ja das kann man sich heute
nicht vorstellen solche spielchen hat
sich da das bild von ihrem vater
geändert und auch in der kurzen zeit
danach bei der war ja dafür
verantwortlich was wieder ja überhaupt
nicht ich meine wussten ja nicht was
hast du dich passiert war ne also und
der stadt ja auch nicht in den zeitungen
so ja ich habe ja damals schon zeitung
gelesen und jeden tag ab 9 habe ich
jeden tag zwei dominieren wobei
natürlich die sich nicht so schrecklich
unterschieden ja diese drei gesteuert
alles von goebbels aber lokale sachen
kann sich schon und da kam dann auch
natürlich
bevor wir abgeholt wurden im lokalblatt
das war hieß der wille organ der nsdap
für den kreis balingen und weil sie also
meine großmutter die hat österreich die
stuttgarter stuttgarter neues tagblatt
das wurde eingestellt zugunsten des
kuriers und da kann es auch jeden tag ob
das dann noch weiter lief als sie dann
vater das weiß ich nehme mir aber
jedenfalls da standen wurde schon
berichtet über die ersten prozesse
warum volksgerichtshof ja bei denen also
der bruder meines vaters ja auch mit als
angeklagter war das mein vater erspart
geblieben
und das habe ich alles mitgekriegt
sie hatten bereits erwähnt dass nach dem
attentat ihre mutter nachts aus dem bett
geholt wurde von den nazis und dass sie
quasi am nächsten morgen zusammen mit
ihren geschwistern ohne mutter wach
geworden sind was passiert dann
übernimmt dann der älteste sozusagen die
kleine kinder schwester ja sie hat
praktisch übernommen
wir waren ja immer noch in ferien großen
sommerferien sind schließlich auch aus
den sommerferien noch in das kinderheim
gebracht worden also dann hat man ja
nicht fürchterliche angst also die
vorstellung aufzuwachen
die mutter ist weg abgeholt wussten sie
was passiert war und hat man eigentlich
an
na ja sicher also das ist ja dass sie
verhaftet worden war ja also nachdem die
uns das mitgeteilt hat mein vater
irgendwie ohne das auszusprechen
aber da mit allem gerechnet
also ich kann in der rückschau aber weil
sie sich so genau wie natürlich auch
nicht nichts sagen da sich darüber
besonders überrascht war er wie können
sie sich noch an den moment erinnern als
dann noch sie abgeholt wurden wie war
das
naja du wir saßen da natürlich so ein
bisschen im ungewissen ab da und ab ohne
es auszusprechen oder nicht gewusst
passieren würde aber dass irgendwas
passieren würde dann die nachricht dass
wir also dann weg kommen sollten kann
dann doch etwas überraschend
mitte august er wusste also die unsere
kinder schwester muss dann alles
zusammenpacken so was wir mit hatten was
ja eigentlich nur für die ferien gedacht
war ja und unsere kleider bestände waren
damals kriegsbedingt sowieso nicht so
reichhaltig ja dann ist es ja am
nächsten tag werden wir also dann
abgeholt und in ein heim kommen
und tatsächlich ist also bei nächst
jüngere bruder und ich mit einem vor
diesen gestapo beamten mit der bahn nach
stuttgart gefahren umsteigen in tübingen
und die anderen mit dem auto
so kamen wir alle zusammen da weiß ich
ob sie jetzt mal gehört haben
vor dem hotel silber das ist natürlich
nur stuttgarter oder farben das war das
ehemalige hotel war schon lange kann es
schnell gewesen
das war das gestapo hauptquartier und da
wollen wir alle gesammelt und dann
wollen wir haben es mit einer
begleitperson den zug gesetzt
schnell zog von konstant sagt berlin
über schweinfurt erfurt
der ford umgestiegen nach nordhausen und
da sind wir abgeholt worden und erst
dann wussten wir nicht wo wir hinkommen
und da war erst das eben dieses bad
sachsa was wir in so einem zipfel gerade
noch in thüringen war
im gau thüringen nicht im land thüringen
rüsten sie was die nazis mit ihnen
vorhaben gab es da einen plan wie weit
das war natürlich die korrosion
gewissheit was passiert wenn du das
eigentlich
wer wusste ja nicht mal was mit unseren
familien passiert waren meine mutter zu
sichern 23 juli 44 und pasta 16 juli 45
ja nicht mehr gesehen
wenn man abends im bett liegt alleine
und an seine mutter denkt was was kommen
andere gedanken drüber
das waren natürlich gedanken waren beim
einschlafen also hatte noch
ich kann nicht sagen dass ich noch an
den endsieg geglaubt habe aber so sicher
war ich mir auch nicht noch nie wieder
krieg ausgehen würde also bevor wir
verhaftet wurden dabei also die
geschichte mit den vergeltungs schaffen
denn frau waffen ja woran die propaganda
große zuversicht zu vermitteln versucht
hat aber ich weiß mein vater das letzte
mal auf besuch war im juni anfang juni
da passierte die alliierten landung in
der normandie
ich erinnere mich dass ich mein vater
die zeitung gezeigt habe und wollte ich
wissen was das zu bedeuten da sagt dann
war da nichts sondern schultern gezuckt
glaube ich so obwohl sie nicht dazu
äußern
und du war bei dem kinderheim und eines
tages kriege ich irgendwie mit war das
im oktober daran dass die amerikaner in
aachen sind auf deutschem boden
und das war ein schock
ja und
und das heißt also einer von den eltern
wird uns sehr gut fand das hat ja da war
ich ja auch schockiert ja aber war nicht
die idee dieses kinderheims auch dass
sie quasi umerzogen werden dass sie es
doch immer zu erzielen
vielleicht also wann wird sich von der
vorstellung verabschieden dass die nazis
ordentlich und systematisch waren
und da ist alles von oben befohlen wurde
da gab es so viele kleine führer die
befohlen haben und dass da ging so oft
konträr und unabgestimmt und wer da
gerade ein befehl gegeben hat ohne sich
genügend abgestimmt zu haben mit anderen
das war reiner zufall
was und wahrscheinlich ist die
vorstellung was wir uns machen
mehrfach geändert worden
je nachdem wer sie da gerade
durchgesetzt hat hinten himmler hat ja
mal erklärt dass die familie
stauffenberg die grafen stauffenberg ja
hallo dass sie zwischen dem grafen und
den frei haben bis ins letzte glied
ausgelöscht wurde
da der frau leiter den endlosen erklärt
nur das haben sie nicht gemacht
sie haben einen neuen namen bekommen ja
wir haben wir haben dann muss uns eines
tages eröffnet dass wir jetzt als wir
speziell meister hieß aber ich hatte die
gelegenheit jemand anderes mit meister
vorzustellen hier war der andere kam
nicht so viel haben sie darüber wird
spekuliert
also es gab eine theorie also weiter
seine schwester hofacker schwer cousine
hofacker hat gemeint doch auch daraus
zugelegt zu haben
das was die namen von familien ss
familien oder was waren zu denen wir der
nach dem kriege hätten kommen sollen
drastisch waren wir ja einwandfrei
wann haben sie bad sachsa land verlassen
das heim ja tatsächlich verlassen am 12
juni 45 also eine ganze weile nach dem
krieg speziell wo wir ja schon ab dem 12
april glaub ich von den amerikanern und
besetzt waren
da war für uns der krieg zu ende obwohl
ja noch drei wochen ging
erzählen sie doch mal davon wie das
erzählen sie doch mal von der zeit war
sie ihres persönlichen kriegsendes nun
ja also wir sollten ja klappen haben
wird obwohl also was ostermontag
sollten wir und wohin kommen wohin wurde
nicht gesagt aber es ist wohl klar dass
es buchen weil sein sollte das kz
buchenwald wo die erwachsenen bei der
familie oder unserer familiären die da
waren aber durch meine mutter waren für
eine zeit lang war es da also außerhalb
des engeren lee endlagers oder ahnt wie
ip bereich gab ja der auch probiert
wurde von amerikanern oder was dass also
die presse ist unwahr fall da von hessen
tochter des italienischen königs ums
leben gekommen beim bombenangriff
und wir sollten also dann wurden nach
nordhausen gebracht werden
und wie wir danach 2001 kam ging ein
väterlicher bombenangriff los und es
stand nur durch seinen beeindruckenden
baum werkstattwagen ja so einen
kastenwagen mit fenstern bafin sondern
muss man sagen wer zuerst haben wir
gesagt das ist schwere flac die da
knallt aber das war eben ja und wir
lagen da drin am boden manchmal ein
bisschen rausgeschaut ja da ist vorbei
war
ob die wussten dass ja kein zug mehr am
bahnhof gehen würde oder doch vermutet
habe jedenfalls wurde wie vater
abgebrochen und wir sind wieder zurück
nach bad sachsa
denn das heim noch noch einen umweg über
stolberg im harz und so aber war zwar
wieder bad sachsa und blieb dann
allerdings leben weiter wie erlebt man
denn als zehnjähriger sohn pumpen
angriffs auf einem kastenwagen also im
gegensatz zu vielen anderen damals hat
war das der erste richtige bombenangriff
den ich erlebt habe
der wird wo verträge blieben dann wäre
das natürlich alle das land passiert und
ganz in der nähe von das war doch ein
bauernhof ja soweit in der stadt der
welt ist hat einen volltreffer
das hat wäre ich nicht naja das
natürlich aber angst gehabt noch und
gehofft dass es vorbei geht was pro bahn
geführt sind ja immer vorbeigegangen
irgendwie ne frage war sah es danach aus
sie haben die explosionen
ja und auch die einschläge zum teil
gesehen ja aber nicht sehr viele war
dann so ganz nah dann doch nicht weil
die wenn sie gewollt hätten der der
begleitschutz natürlich mit den jägern
den laster angreifen können
so ist ja alle naslang passiert
tieffliegerangriffe wer nachher ja auch
noch erlebt da das schaffst du sie also
unterhalb war so ein erdbeerfeld vor dem
gebäude wo wir drin waren erschossen sie
rein
das war die maschine nivea oder kanonen
und ja dann kam der amerikaner
wie waren die amerikaner zu ihren
kindern die amerikaner gar nicht wann
ich freundlich zwar nicht unfreundlich
aber sehr bedrohlich habe mir sonst
verschieden ist es nicht weiter
bedrohlich haben sie in der ganzen zeit
auch über das schicksal ihrer familie
nach gedacht also natürlich ja was hat
ihnen ihre mutter erzählt von dem was
wir hatten ja einmal besuch von meiner
von der tante melitta war die frau vom
mittleren bruder meines vaters und die
fliegerin und ingenieuren die hat sachen
entwickeln selber ausprobiert ja ja ich
glaube wenn jemand hat so viele
sturzflüge absolviert wie sie kein mann
und die hatten sie auch kurz verhaftet
aber dann braucht sie sehe dann würde
sie also raus gelassen
aber sie hat sich zur weiterarbeit nur
erklärt oder der bedingung dass sie
ihren mann besuchen darf in der haft
oder wie hat sie es geschafft also auch
uns zu besuchen eben da an weihnachten
entwachsen und die hat gesagt also
meiner mutter ging es gut
das war ja noch vor der geburt meine
schwester und hat meiner mutter auch
erzählt dann aber näheres wusste ja auch
nicht weiß noch nicht was ihre mutter
der durchmacht würde wussten sie auch
nicht was ihre mutter durch macht quasi
oder nein ich meine sie hat ja gesagt
dass wir ein kind erwartet darüber dass
wir die aufgabe haben sie später mit
ihrer mutter noch mal darüber gesprochen
was sie erlebt hat
im konzentrationslager haben sie später
noch mal mit ihrer mutter darüber
gesprochen was sie erlebt hat in
konzentrationslager ja ja das hat das
auch niedergeschrieben
also sie war also echt im
konzentrationslager war es überhaupt
nicht
sie war zunächst so genannte lex
polizeipräsidium alexanderplatz also
ziemlich schrecklich fand und dann kam
sie eben in nach ravensbrück und da war
das waren für sich an frauen kz aber
anwerben kommandantur gebäude außerhalb
des eigentlichen lagers gab es einen
zellenblock für untersuchungshäftlinge
da war sie oder brachte war auch nicht
nur frauen noch männer ja
und dann haben sie natürlich versucht
raus zu kriegen was sie weiß ob sie was
wusste haben sie dich rausgekriegt aber
sie wurde
ich glaube auch angesichts ihrer
schwangerschaft wurde sie relativ also
korrekt und zurückhaltend behandelt und
dann ja dass das die geburt näher kam
war sie jetzt am anfang ich dachte das
sei nur ein paar tage gewesen da kann
sehen ein in ein heim das waren
eigentlich entschloss wenn wir jetzt den
namen nicht 61 kilometer etwa östlich
von frankfurt an der oder und da hätte
sie das baby kriegen sollen aber das
wurde kurzfristig also paar tage vorher
geräumt für flüchtlinge und dann kam sie
nach frankfurt an der oder und schließt
sieht eine privatklinik und da wurde das
geworden und wann haben sie ihre mutter
wieder gesehen
anfang juli 45 also als wir dann von bad
sachsa wegkamen kann sich auch nicht
vorstellen aber die verbindungen in
deutschland waren ja weitgehend
zusammengebrochen ja post telefon usw
auch straßen vielerorts nicht
passierbare werde wurden gesprengt waren
und das muss soll sich erstmal jemand
finden können sie sich noch an den
moment erinnern wo sie ihre mutter
endlich wieder gesehen haben können sie
sich noch an den moment des wiedersehens
erinnern mit ihrer mutter jan o also
dann wurde ein auto mobil gemacht das
war alles nicht so einfach abfinden
jemand finden der ein auto hatte er
dafür die erlaubnis hatte von den
franzosen passierschein für die
amerikaner und genügend benzin und dann
durfte ich mitfahren haben sie abgeholt
in der nähe von hof ist das erste mal
wieder gesehen
das baby natürlich dass du erstmal
überhaupt gesehen war nicht sehr gesund
das bms ist
und dann haben wir uns wieder auf den
weg da auf die schwäbische alb gemacht
das finde ich total schwer von außen
betrachtet so eine zeit so ein jahr zu
resümieren zu bilanzieren aber wenn sie
versuchen das zusammenzufassen
wie hat sie diese zeit geprägt dieses
eine jahr
naja das hat sie ja war für meine
entwicklung sicher auch wichtig ja
das jetzt zu trennen von der zeit vorher
krieg und so weiter schule im krieg und
ich meine wir wieder alle zusammen aber
das leben war ja auch dann nicht einfach
und wenn sie ihren vater heute
betrachten sehen sie ihn als vorbild und
fraß sie natürlich was hätte außerdem
werden können ja 36 ja kein alter
versuche ihn mir auch vorzustellen in
dem alter in dem ich jetzt bin oder
bisschen weniger ist natürlich was
würden sie ihren vater gerne fragen wenn
sie ihn etwas fragen könnten nach gott
auch diese frage hatte sich vorher
vorbereiten dürfen also eine frage
natürlich
die habe ich schon weiter beantwortet
ist warum hat er die zweite sprengladung
aus der tasche genommen
meine antwort ist er wusste nicht dass
sie mit hochgehen würde oder zünder
warum muss das nicht
weil ich gut genug ausgebildet war ein
kavalleristen damals keine pioniere
ausbildung gekriegt und das ist bei der
bundeswehr ist gewesen ja ich hatte
einen sprechen berechtigungsscheine zum
beispiel und er hat den blick
wissen sie wahrscheinlich ja da nicht
die zeit und die zweite sprengladung
scharf zu machen
hat er haften wahrscheinlich und
eingesteckt haben und dann haben sie auf
dem weg nach draußen
nachdem der sprengung weggeschmissen und
igstadt bord sind dann über die ss hat
sie dann gefunden doch noch
aber die hätte flecken den unterschied
gemacht
das hätte vielleicht einiges verändern
er stelle sich das manchmal vor wende
erfolgte also ob hitler das überlebt hat
er wieder die zweite sprengladung mit
hochgegangen wäre in einem ja das halte
ich doch für fraglich aber wirst du es
keiner was empfinden sie wenn sie in
ihren fall denken na ja zu denken wir
natürlich großes bedauern dass wir nicht
länger gehabt zu haben
wie schon gesagt ohne vater aufzuwachsen
war in meiner generation ist eigentlich
normal aber doch sehr hofft sie hat uns
gefehlt
natürlich
wie auch gefragt wie er wohl mit der
ganzen entwicklung vor allem die
politischen entwicklungen nach dem
kriege umgegangen wäre oder auch zurecht
gekommen wären verfolgen sie eigentlich
wie sich die fdp bei ihrem vater äußern
die fdp werde für sie ein vorbild wäre
nun sind die auch gespalten sich nach
und aber auch immer wieder mal versucht
mich damit einzuspannen weil es in
letzter zeit nicht mehr aber so dass das
geht ja schon länger es gibt zwar eine
gewisse tendenz hängt auch zusammen da
wir es sieht eine zeitschrift junge
freiheit junge freiheit genau aber wir
in unserer familie
wir wollen nicht dass es also lügen
verbreitet werden natürlich ja aber wir
lassen uns nicht einspannen für
politische zwecke diese oder jene auch
wenn zum ehrungen geht also mein
standpunkt war immer meine gebote
schwester genauso öffentliche ehrungen
meines vaters sind sache der
öffentlichkeit nicht unsere wir stellen
uns nicht dagegen wir unterstützen worum
gebeten werden aber aktiv machen wir das
nicht
wie beurteilen sie denn die die heutige
zeit viele sagen ja dass unsere
gesellschaft sich gerade wieder in eine
gefährliche richtung bewegt also
ich glaube dass das etwas übertrieben
ist aber bei der eine gewisse gefahr
dass lehren vergessen werden besteht
natürlich die leute die sich nicht mehr
erinnern können weil sie nie erlebt
haben ja dass wir meinen dinge wieder
neu zu entdecken aufzuwärmen
die wir schon nun ich persönlich
persönlich glaube es geht uns einfach zu
gut
wir können uns jetzt solche faxen
leisten glauben leute weil sie sozusagen
sind natürlich nicht ist auch nicht
bewusst
aber wer weiß noch wie es ist wenn es
einem wirklich schlecht geht
ich bin außerdem sagen mal sozial
benachteiligter ist aber wenn es allen
schlecht geht ja ihr könnt doch die ich
mir vorstellen sie können sich nicht
mehr vorstellen dass sie nicht keinen
urlaub mehr haben zu dem sie auch noch
ins ausland fahren können dass sie dort
alles kaufen können was wir wollen ja
richtig not ist nicht mehr vorstellbar
wo dann alle zusammen helfen lassen
würden sie denn der jugend von heute da
gerne mal was mit auf den weg geben
quasi aus ihrer ganzen erinnern wie man
solche sachen zu simulieren ist
natürlich sehr schwierig aber ich warne
ich die sache auch immer und freiheit
ist wie hunger ja
aber man kann es nicht simulieren wenn
ich heute jemand essen wegnehme für eine
weile sagt jetzt höchst zumal hunger
dabei ist ja genau es geht vorbei und
dann kriege ich wieder das entscheidende
ist dass man nicht weiß ich den ausweg
weil es das ende davon
was ist denn im rückblick wie sie wenn
sie darauf die ganze zeit schauen das
schlimmste an das sie sich erinnern
das schlimmste an der ganzen zeit da war
sicher die jugend gewissheit über unser
schicksal und das seiner familie
da konnte einfach keiner helfen die
wusste es ja auch nicht
aber wie gesagt kriegsende das war für
uns ein tag zum abhaken ja der krieg war
für uns schon lange vorbei als das
passierte sie das auch gar nicht so
bewusst
du kannst ja auch zeitungen dann wieder
gelesen also nun ist waffenstillstand
und so reims und pankow aber eine
praktische bedeutung hat das für uns
nicht
herr general vielen dank wir sind fertig
jeden tag dass auch gott ich weiß wenn
sie es auch nicht
nicht denken und rechnen sollten sie auf
die idee kommen zu glauben ich sei jetzt
waren sie gespannt darauf was jetzt
dabei rauskommt dann muss ich
enttäuschen
es ist völlig bin ich unhöflich werden
das ist völlig in ordnung oder war sehr
schön
dann machen wir die mikros genau